ever since tesla set out to accelerate
the world's transition to sustainable
energy in 2003
they have been consistently knocking it
out of the park cars as impressive as a
tesla
need an impressive workspace and
efficient production line and there's no
doubt they have both down pat
located in fremont california the tesla
hq and factory
spans 5.3 million square feet and
employs over 10
000 people but how does it work inside
today we're going to take a rare peek
inside the fremont facility before we
dive in welcome back to our channel
if you haven't already make sure you hit
the subscribe button and ring the bell
so you never miss a video from us
tesla milestones after delivering a
record number of evs in the fourth
quarter of 2020 tesla is preparing for
an even bigger year with global
expansion in the cards
it hit its goal of delivering half a
million cars in 2020 but it can barely
keep up with production so
to solve that little problem tesla
gigafactories have been cropping up
around the world for some time now
even with that limitation tesla has done
quite well for itself
tesla's first car was the roadster and
its debut proved that electric cars
could be just as fast as any fossil
burning vehicle
next came tesla's model s in 2012 to
prove teslas could be luxurious
soon after tesla established its
supercharger network allowing ev owners
to finally take long road trips without
worrying about range
in 2015 tesla set its sights on
semi-self-driving systems and started
actively working towards achieving full
autonomous driving
during all that tesla launched a red
roadster into space announced the tesla
semi in the most rock concert-like
reveal
and kept way above general motors and
ford's market value
despite being the new kid in school now
how are they pulling that off
elon musk's social presence definitely
helps with marketing the brand but
marketing isn't everything
you need a good product and tesla is
arguably one of the very best
and with no small thanks to its highly
efficient production and assembly line
tesla headquarters and factory tesla's
factory in california
is unsurprisingly one of the world's
most advanced automotive plants sitting
on 370 acres of land
elon musk calls it a machine that builds
machines and rightly so
this was tesla's first large-scale
production facility ever
and it opened in 2010 now of course they
have several massive gigafactories
around the world but this is where it
all started
the head of the operation or the central
nervous system is the tesla fremont
offices
just like in the spacex offices elon
musk prefers not to have walls and
cubicles in his workspace
because it limits conversation and the
flow of ideas so instead you have
everyone from designers to engineers
working together to create
magic the actual assembly in production
of course happens just below these
offices in the factory
unlike its other factories the fremont
factory wasn't built from scratch
this facility used to be home to general
motors from 1962 to 1982 before toyota's
new united motor manufacturing
incorporated or
numi swooped in to buy it for 800
million dollars toyota
then sold this 800 million dollar
factory on may 20th 2010
for just 59 million dollars and it
included much of the manufacturing
equipment too
and you thought you were good at
bargaining what followed was some
extensive remodeling of the offices in
the factory the floors were painted
white
and a lot of the machinery was painted
red a fresh modern update for a modern
car
to brighten up a once dark space tesla
added skylights to provide workers with
natural sunlight
the offices went from a dull drab space
to a clean
modern looking lit up work area with new
systems the tesla headquarters also has
an employee training center a cafeteria
several food trucks on campus a fully
fitted state-of-the-art gym
and a 24 7 in-house medical center yep
tesla takes good care of their workers
in the factory everything is automatic
the fremont factory is home to the model
and the assembly lines for it are
heavily automated to eliminate the more
difficult and repetitive tasks
and the need to lift heavy awkward parts
there was a time tesla had too many
robots
and even elon musk admitted that
excessive automation at tesla was a
mistake
but now they seem to have found a
balance between robots and humans
now tesla has a criteria for when to use
humans and when to use robots
basically machines are great at working
with parts that are always the same size
like metal bolts batteries and battery
packs but when it comes to working with
fabrics
belts and wires humans are better the
system that controls the whole intricate
process of assembling the model 3
is tesla's manufacturing operating
system and it's all created by software
engineers
sitting in the tesla offices typically
the job of making the operating system
is outsourced
making their own system has enabled them
to fine-tune the equipment and processes
sure it's more expensive but with a
market valuation of over 800 billion
it probably makes the smallest most
unnoticeable dent making their own
operating system also gives them
flexibility
so they can develop or change their
equipment before a competitor would even
be able to get a formal proposal
together to send to its supplier
in addition to assembling the car and
giving it the final touches the fremont
location is also a manufacturer for key
components of the vehicle
in fact the tesla campus includes
several smaller buildings dedicated to
making various vehicle components
for example there's a whole unit just
for manufacturing tesla seats
just minutes away from the headquarters
it's a rather plain looking factory and
doesn't get as much light as the main
factory but it has still made a name for
itself in the auto industry
the seats that go into tesla's vehicles
are not just any seats but world-class
automotive seats that are assembled with
vegan fabric
which is actually superior to regular
leather in every noteworthy way
tesla's vegan leather seats are
aesthetically beautiful durable
highly stain resistant super soft and of
course
eco-friendly but this is far from high
tech if you want something more complex
tesla also has units dedicated to making
autopilot hardware and battery
management systems
once the car is assembled and painted it
goes for inspection where they are
checked top to bottom for the slightest
flaws
they are then taken for testing which
hopefully goes better than this
at its peak the tesla headquarters can
produce half a million cars a year
thanks to their highly efficient staff
of 10 000 people and 200 robots
each robot costs approximately 50
thousand dollars and each has its own
specified role
they are also named after superhero
characters like xavier from the x-men
comics which sits at the entrance of the
trim line
the robots wolverine and beast do all
the heavy lifting
storm and colossus are found at the end
of the chassis line the great thing
about tesla is they don't claim to have
reached the peak of car manufacturing
despite their incredible assembly and
production line
temporary engineering workstations are
set up in the middle of the production
line to troubleshoot the equipment
sometimes you'll see partially finished
cars pulled out of the assembly line to
correct any body shape issues before
being sent off for a paint job
the new tesla gigafactories this is by
no means the only facility manufacturing
cars at an insane scale
tesla currently has four gigafactories
around the world the nevada base which
is 1.5 million square feet the new york
base which is focused on solar energy
more than vehicles
there's one in shanghai which is the
newest one and handles the final
assembly of the model 3 and production
of the model y
and the berlin base which is still not
operational but will be soon
new hq in texas but the most impressive
of them
will be the texas gigafactory this 1.1
billion dollar assembly plant in the
south travis county of austin will be
tesla's fifth gigafactory in the world
the site space is 2500 acres and the
factory is a whopping 4 to 5 million
square feet
while fremont is currently still the hq
of tesla don't expect that to be the
case for too long
in may elon musk threatened to move
tesla to texas after local authorities
refused to let him open his factory
during the pandemic
in response to that he tweeted tesla
will now move its hq and future programs
to texas nevada immediately
if we even retain fremont manufacturing
activity at all it will be dependent on
how tesla is treated in the future and
of course the texas government welcomed
tesla and elon musk with open arms
giving him approvals and a massive tax
cut of 50 million dollars
texas also doesn't collect personal
income tax while california has some of
america's highest state tax rates
texas also supported tesla's federal
request for designation as a foreign
trade zone which means they would be
exempt from paying customs on materials
used in export production
if a billionaire promises thousands of
jobs and opportunities
that's how you treat them the texas
factory is expected to create over 5 000
jobs in the next four years
and tesla is already hiring for several
manufacturing and engineering positions
in the facility
anyone interested better apply fast
while the fremont factory is obviously
impressive something tells us tesla
hasn't even begun
to explore its options in manufacturing
systems yet if there's one thing you can
be sure of with elon musk
it's that he will find a way to upgrade
everything he can get his hands on
and make the process faster to meet the
insanely high demands of the market
so we might just be back with another
video talking about the brand new
factory and brand new systems and
processes
what do you think of the fremont
facility let us know in the comments
below
if you enjoyed this video make sure to
give it a like and check out more
awesome ones on the simply tech channel
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time